this is steve and this is steve's uncle
and steve is in a bit of a bind not only
does he not have any money but he also
owes michael who is not depicted here he
owes michael three dollars so he
actually has a negative net worth steve
has a net worth of negative three
steve's uncle cares about steve and and
feels bad that he's he doesn't even have
a zero net worth he has a negative net
worth and so steve's uncle wants to at
least take away some of this pain he at
least wants to get steve back to a
neutral net worth a zero net worth and
so he decides to take away he decides to
take away
steve's negative
negative net worth so he wants to take
away that negative three well what
happens if you take away that negative
three
well that should get you back to zero if
you take away anything if you have
something and you take it away it should
go back to zero so similarly if you owe
people things and that that owing people
things is taken away it also gets back
to you zero and another way to think
about it is how steve's uncle would
actually take that liability take that
debt away from steve well the easiest
way he could do it if steve is starting
at negative three net worth is for his
uncle to just give steve three dollars
is to just give him three dollars so
that he can get back to a net worth of
zero so hopefully that makes it a little
bit clearer that this
and this are intuitively equivalent